I meet a girl named Amanda Gardner well
what I end up doing is keep mind I've
only got a 100,000 or so so I go and I
start buying houses in the area in this
area called JC Napier next to it's just
close to downtown and I buy these houses
and I start Rec I buy them for like 60
70,000 and I record the sales at 210 190
1 2 205 that sort of thing same thing
and I refinance the house as I start
pulling out
money I meet this girl uh Amanda Gardner
she we we hit it off within a few months
she's moved in to we move into a house
in that area I renovate a house we move
in
there I borrow $3.5 million and I'm
buying houses now I'm buying houses
recording the value I start all over you
know I borrow like whatever $35 million
I meet aanda we move in together uh
we're we're we're do you tell her do you
tell her she kind of you know what she
knew was that you know it's it's it's
odd right I have no photographs
everything I own is brand new she's like
you don't there's nothing in this house
that's more than four months old so six
months old you have no photographs you
have no internet presence you have no
you know it's every stick of clothing is
brand new you don't have old pairs of
jeans do do you tell their stories about
the past of like is there a fabric
the init initially there was a
fabricated version that I owned a I
owned a mortgage
company um my typical story was like I
owned a mortgage company and I got
bought out by Household Bank started
doing very well I got bought out by
Household Bank I have a no non-compete
Clause I got you know I ended up with
like half a million dollars after paying
off all my bills uh and just decided to
kind of travel around the the US and now
I'm here I'm going to start renovating
houses but that you know you don't call
home nobody calls you your family
doesn't call you you tell stories about
your mom your dad your brother your
sister friends I don't know any of these
friends never seen any of these friends
they never call you they never you know
it's just like it's like a [__] so at
some point I basically just said to her
look I'm listen at one point I had to
have a check cut I refinance the house
right and I had like I want to say I'm
going to say something like it might
have been 30,000 but let's say 20,000 a
$20,000 check cut to Amanda Garder M cuz
you have to have these checks you can't
have them cut to me so I would say hey
there's a second mortgage on there and
I'd provide a second mortgage or I'd
provide you know i' provide different
things and I knew if I I need names of
people to cut these things to so I had a
check cut for whatever so I remember
we're at dinner one night this is before
she really knows who I am and I said hey
uh I said oh and she go oh did you had a
refine she go how'd that thing go you're
refinance I would oh thank God you said
that boom I said I need you to deposit
this give check for 20,000 she's like um
I can I can I can go tomorrow and and I
can deposit it and I um um and I'm like
no no I'm like look it's fine just
deposit so I can get as soon as it
clears I I I'll get you a cashier check
um I was like No just deposit it and
keep it in your bank it's fine so she's
like what is going on you know and so we
have this conversation and I tell her
look people are looking for me who law
enforcement which ones all of them you
know she's like that doesn't even what
for what I
go mostly bank fraud and she's like well
how are they not finding you MH I mean
everybody you know people know you like
you know your general contractor which I
met four months before this guy 6 months
before this one two months before you
know she's like so and so so and so so
and I'm like right right well I said
well she's like I mean they've got your
name they've got your well that's
identity theft and she was like what do
you mean I said well my name's not you
know my name's not it's not Joseph
Carter and what is your what is your
name I go look you know it's it's you
don't need don't even worry about it
this is what's happening this is where
I'm at this has been months into the
relationship I mean this is or i' say
maybe a month or two in but you know she
was just too inquisitive and oh I know
what it was she found like $40,000 in
cash in my freezer one night that was
another thing that happened she went to
get a popsicle and she opened up the the
flip to get a popsicle and she opened
the wrong one and it was all cash and
she was like like you know I the other
day you know in this conversation she
like the other day I opened up the
popsicle box and there's cash and I'm
like so I kind of explain it but I had a
feeling she's not going to she's going
to be okay with this you know so she was
okay she was okay with this like I mean
to me that's just a fascinating
conversation to have like it was a great
conversation because often times in
relationships you learn about each other
and you find out new things and here you
find out that's a doozy yeah it's a good
one to find
out that the name you're using is not
your real name and the Secret Service
the FBI and everybody else are looking
for you yeah and you're like to be
honest you're not a violent criminal so
it's like and I you know you know but
she didn't know my name like she was
like
she and I told her I said' look if you
start digging if you find out my name
like I'll leave like there's certain
things that catch you staying in contact
with people that you know that's how you
get caught you know going back to see
people that's how you get caught you
know um telling people who you are
that's how you get caught and I was like
so I'm Joseph
Carter everything's fine and she was
like okay you know and keep in mind too
this girl do you you oh your car is
broken or your car's not doing well take
it and trade it in we'll go get you
another car we'll go get you you know an
Infinity you know FX or whatever you
know a $555,000 $60,000 vehicle she's
driving the equivalent of a a beat up
old Nova you know I mean it's you want
to go on vacation we'll go on vacation
you want to do this you want to do that
so you know we're buying houses I I'm
we're we're renovating houses we're
we're building brand new houses we're
buying Lots like she's like in the
middle of this like holy Jesus there's
hundreds of thousands of dollars in the
bank in our bank account uh her bank
account I open up a corporation in her
name she's opening up bank accounts
she's got web there's websites it's it's
a lot and while this is
happening we start seeing a a a friend
of hers so this other girl comes in the
picture her name's Trina and um Trina is
is
um semi- lesbian
so is is like a sexual thing or actual
relationship no it's no it's more like a
she's coming over a couple times a week
okay so we've got a ton of a tons going
on uh
and I put this so while this is
happening I I end up coming out in like
several magazines so I'm thinking this
whole thing's dying down but it's not
dying down because now I just got caught
and handcuffed in a bank walked out of
the police station outran Marshalls
although that in that part the Marshall
thing never was never in the papers
but um the getting caught and handcuffed
in the bank when that hit the papers
that's everywhere bro that's huge you
know suddenly Chicago Tribune's running
a series The fugitives um I'm in
Bloomberg business week they run an
articles article called you know sharks
in the housing pool pool uh then you've
got a Fortune Magazine comes out with a
thing because by now guess what Becky's
been caught oh Becky Becky Becky is she
in Houston or whatever in Houston got
caught and did she but gangster bro like
the way she here's the thing hey there
you go no oh no she told on me
immediately oh she did oh no it's fine
she do the right thing so here here's
what's funny about that I don't know
about that she here's what she says
loyalty is everything world my friend
that you and I disagree on I just took
off I just took off still onor and left
her with with with listen with like six
or like five or $600,000 is what I left
her with it's not it's not all about
money Matthew it's also about just like
you know ride or die there's a meaning
to that my God I'm sorry go ahead she
told she said everything well here's
what what when I say gangster when she
gets caught yeah um they come in she's
in the middle of beauty school she's
paid for beauty school she's going
through beauty school she's going to
open like a salon or something so she's
in there cutting hair in a class you
know on a mannequin and all of a sudden
like five or six Secret Service agents
come in guns drawn screaming get on the
ground get on the ground she said
everybody dropped the ground she said
I'm sitting there with scissors
going you know they grab her they
handcuff her they bring her in and the
whole time now at that point she was
Rebecca well she was yeah her name was
Rebecca hickey she went by Becca she so
she's Rebecca hickey which is you know
it's she's got a Texas driver's license
the whole thing and they're screaming at
her and they she they put her in the car
and they're driving the whole way she
goes the guy the secret service agent
told me 45 minutes she's telling us
you're losing your job bro you're losing
I mean he he's like I I couldn't believe
it like we we got pictures of her we're
like this is you she's like that's not
me are you insane look at that chubby
little thing yeah she would not budge
till they actually put her hand on the
scanner and she goes okay I'm I'm
Rebecca Hal what do you
need they're like where's Matt Cox she's
I have no idea that [__] left me like
a year ago
so um so but she contributed to the
story to the legend that's already
growing oh oh because she was
interviewed by uh Fortune Magazine and
it was horrendous the article is
horrendous he was abusive he he's a Don
Juan that that forced me to fall in love
with him commit mortgage fraud and then
took all the money and left by the way
they found like 40 or 50 Grand on her
and maybe another 30 or 40 in her bank
account and no other
money yeah where's the other money um so
anyway and she was by the way she got
caught she was in communication with her
family was so she's talking to her mom
she got caught and her mother through
multiple conversations one conversation
being Mom I'm doing fine I can't tell
you where I am you know exactly but I
I'm in Houston Texas I'm fine next one
six months later I enrolled in Beauty
School Houston Texas Beauty School how
many are there Y and her mom bipolar I
just want to see my daughter yeah I'm
going to call the Secret Service yep I'm
doing the right thing yeah and and
honestly she is doing the right thing so
um